all along the way birds have accompanied
the Exodus toward permanent waters
almost as one they began heading
upstream following the multitudes of
fish having finished mating they came
and follow quickening their pace
upstream
many will find their way to the fabled
cayman lake which few humans have laid
eyes on
[Music]
reputed to be a Cayman paradise it may
keep the reptiles safe through the worst
of the dry season and give the next
generation of fighting chance of
survival against daunting odds
[Music]
finally the exodus triggered by the dry
season comes to attend
the caiman have reached their watery
Haven
after many grueling miles matriz arrives
among the first waves of caiman entering
the hidden sanctuary
[Music]
this place becomes a crocodilian
carnival during the dry season a
triangle gathering complete with a
smorgasbord of food it is so remote as
to be virtually inaccessible to
outsiders even poachers rarely venture
here
the lake offers both shelter and wild
abundance these waters have been
shrinking since the rains ended trapping
countless fish within a dwindling domain
with so much to eat now and little
threat of poaching these came and have
the chance to grow older and immense
reptiles of record-breaking size may
lurk here some of the male's may break
previous records growing to over 20 feet
and weighing well over half a ton like
all crocodilians black caiman can go for
months without much food with fish
dispersed throughout the flooded forest
during the wet season hunting can be
more difficult
[Music]
whether they're dramatic hunting
techniques stuns their prey or traps
them in open jaws remains a mystery but
in the heat of the midday Sun even the
most avid fisherman needs to stop and
bask
for weeks the lake has been an abundant
feast of fish but now while the males
and juveniles feast
mitrice and other expectant females slip
away from the banquet since arriving at
the caiman Lake she has made the most of
the food in anticipation of her eggs and
now they are ready
[Applause]
[Music]